Fox news reporter John Roberts also made
a fat joke about Chris Christie and then
he ended up apologizing about the joke
why don't they ever joke about Trump's
weight on Fox Trump is obese here is the
joke I guess it's a joke I don't know
from John Roberts to to use a a
modification of a metaphor that we were
using in the panel earlier today it's
like you have two milkshakes right the
Republican party used two milkshakes and
and this one representing almost half
the party because that's what the
polling shows has got one straw in it
and that's Donald Trump's straw right
and the other milkshake which represents
the non Donald Trump part of the
Republican party has how many straws in
it now and now we're going to have Chris
Christie's drawing there and judging by
Chris Christie's physical stature he
could drink a lot of that milkshake if
he wanted to oh boy so okay so standard
Chris Christie fat joke and then John
Roberts uh later apologizing and saying
as soon as it came out of his mouth he
knew it was a mistake uh hey before we
go on I I just want to take a moment to
address something because I really do
feel terrible about it this is now a
very serious and somber John Roberts
earlier on the show I was making an
analogy to describe the Republican voter
pool right and I made a comment that I
meant to be light-hearted but
immediately realized was hurtful toward
Governor Chris Christie I should not
have said what I said I deeply regret it
and I sincerely apologize to the
governor there you go a very sincere and
you can tell he means it because he used
his sincere Anchorman voice as opposed
to the normal voice that he uses so
listen the fat jokes are in poor taste
but I just want someone to explain the
hypocrisy why does Trump get a pass on
his obesity uh Trump has been obese for
as long as he's been in political life
Fox News never brings it up Chris
Christie announces yesterday and there
are already fat jokes on Fox News and
there's sort of this irony where John
Roberts apologizes for making a fat joke
about Chris Christie when this has
actually been something they've been
doing on the network for a while and
Trump has been doing to Chris Christie
for a while as well uh I I don't know
I'm curious to hear from folks in the
audience what is the explanation for
this is it that his loyal loyal
followers truly are the cult members we
believe them to be and so it doesn't
matter they're sort of blinded by their
cult following of trump is it because
they don't actually even care about
obesity it's just what can we use as a
weapon against our opponents if our
opponent's overweight we'll use that but
if the guy we like is overweight we
don't actually care this is the
hypocrisy of the right wing this is the
nasty scapegoating nature of the right
wing they can dish it out they often
can't take it and of course of course of
course of course they are hypocrites
period end of story all of these stories
will be on our Instagram which you can
find by searching Instagram for David
Pacman show